when I arrived at
in the fall of two thousand and one I
quickly became aware of the expanding
interest at Columbia in east asian film
across many of the disciplines at the
University of course we were investing
in the important journals and new
scholarly books that were being
published and we had a very good
collection of east asian films at that
point but we had not really developed
those noteworthy special collections
those unique and ephemeral materials
from which new knowledge and new
interpretations are drawn that is what
defines a research library Amy Heinrich
the star librarian i would say alert at
me some would say lobbied me early about
the importance of the mackinac
collection it was always mr Mackey no
and in the summer of 2002 when I was
invited to give a series of lectures in
Japan I visited mr Mackey no in his home
I still have the late of the aches in my
legs from sitting on the floor for four
hours that afternoon talking to mr
Mackey known as his wife brought in
pictures of tea we talked about his
collection and his life and his long
interest in the scholarship of east
asian film i recall squeezing among the
shelves no the Warrens that we've de
cross the rooms in his home so he could
show me some special item that he had in
the collection I probably did not
realize it at that moment but I am sure
that the seed was planted that the
Mackey no collection would be coming to
columbia the inevitability was there and
so here we are now celebrating this
remarkable resource and it's expanding
availability to students and scholars
and now complemented by what I'm told is
certainly the best east asian film
collection in north america now
administered by a professional staff
that truly understands the importance of
these materials to learning and research
across many fields and supported by a
faculty that demands
excellence in our East Asian collections
and capabilities this combination of
collection professional leadership
supportive faculty is really what
defines research library is going
forward and it is in the Makino
collection that we truly have that
definition captured we are proud to be
the home of the Mac you know East Asian
Film Archive at Columbia University
allow me to introduce Bob Himes the
walpole carpenter professor of Chinese
history and chair of the department of
East Asian language and culture at
Columbia